You wrote the book, American cosmic, UFOs,
religion technology. What was the goal of writing this book? What,
uh, maybe we'll mention it. We have already mentioned it many times,
but in this little space of a conversation,
can you say maybe what is the key insight that you found that lingers with you
to this day from the process, the long process of, uh,
putting this book together? Sure.
Just like with my book on purgatory, um,
I went into the research thinking that it would be something that it was
entirely not, it ended up being something completely different.
And I think that's good.
I think that people who do research need to ne are very excited actually when
their research surprises them.
So I was happily surprised by my pro book to learn that it
was a place, you know? And, and so, um,
I went into American,
cosmic being a non-believer in UFO's entirely,
and I came out being agnostic. Okay.
Kind of believer.
But agnostic sort of, uh, open to the mysteries of the world. Yeah.
Yes. And I didn't think that, first of all,
I knew that the government was,
it was part of the situation.
I just didn't know how much.
And so I learned that quickly and acclimated to it,
um,
accepted it and noted that
indeed her ratio,
the world is much more mysterious than we think it
is. It's more mysterious.
There are more mysteries in this life than your philosophy provides for.
So is a sense American cosmic is about the mysteries of the
modern life as encapsulated by this, the,
the realm of technology in the realm of alien intelligences.
Yes. I think that, um, I think that, I mean,
I'd have to go off record as a professor and talk personally as a person.
I do think that, um,
there are mysteries of which we have an inkling
and if it's something as powerful as
non-human intelligence,
whether or not it's from another planet extraterrestrial,
or it happens to be from like another dimension or something else,
I think that this is going to, um,
get the attention of institutions of power. And indeed,
I think that's what has happened. And, um,
although probably he,
people have had interactions with these things.
It appears to me historically, uh, for a long time,
as long as humans have existed,
I would imagine that indeed. Um,
this is something that's quite powerful and could change the belief structures
of our entire societies, our civilization, basically.
So it's the same way that you, them,
the belief structures were strongly effected by religious beliefs throughout
history in the same way. This has the potential, uh,
it, it, uh, serves as, um,
a source of concern for the powerful,
because it can have very significant effects on the populace. Yes.